Speaker 1: All right, let's get into the mail
bag with a couple bonus comments and Facebook
messages this week. We tried this segment
sort of on a whim a few weeks ago, and
people are loving it. And the number of emails
coming in has gone up dramatically. More people
have a lot of things to say. But the reaction
also people are really getting interested by
the things that that people are writing. So let's
just go right to it. Remember, you can send me an
email info at David Pakman dot com. Please don't
send 20 emails. If you do, they're going to get
auto deleted. So just be reasonable. OK, guys,
if you're sending me 20 emails in a day or two,
we're probably not getting them because
you've probably been blocked, my friends. OK,
first message is from Tom about the Veirs system.
That's the vaccine reporting system. Tom says, Hi,
David. I recently looked into the Veirs website
and was stunned to find that individuals are
allowed to very easily report whatever they want
at any given time. I downloaded the Ghab app to
keep up on Magga trends, and they all seem to be
very aware of the acronym Veirs. But it appears as
though only the influenza's on the right know how
unreliable the data actually is. They have begun
and probably have in the past used it to make
wild claims. It's disgusting and disheartening.
I look forward to hearing your take. Thank you,
Tom. Yeah, I've said this before. You can report
anything you want to the very system. And then
that data is used by right wingers to say, look
at all these reports, never mentioning you can
report anything. Now, last time I mentioned this,
someone wrote to me and they said, David, sir. You
know, it's a crime to falsely report, OK, that,
but that's fine. Are we hearing about anybody
getting in trouble for false reports? There's
every indication there are endless false reports.
It should be mentioned. Very, very important.
Kevin from Toronto wrote to me, and this is about
our story about Amazon now pushing for cannabis
legalization. We said, what's the what's the
game here? Kevin says, Hey, David, the thing I
thought of immediately just hearing the headline
that Amazon is pushing for cannabis legalization
is that Amazon could make a lot of money selling
and distributing it. Cannabis is lightweight,
very easy to ship. And many retailers and
producers would surely use an Amazon store if it
was allowed, especially the rapid shipping options
would be very desirable for cannabis customers. I
agree 100 percent. I think, you know, Amazon was
very clear about a lot of this has to do with just
smoothing out the hiring by eliminating cannabis
as an obstacle, which maybe makes sense. But at
the same time, they could just say we don't care
about cannabis use regardless of its legality.
There may be an e-commerce opportunity
there that Amazon is is interested in
many people writing in with that exact
same point of view. Helen wrote in
and says, just the thought when you talk about
governors and their stance on vaccines, please
mention whether they themselves are vaccinated.
I think that when we know that's a great idea,
I don't I'm not sure if we know the vaccination
status of all 50 governors, but if we do a story
about such governor just came out against vaccine
mandates, I think it's perfectly reasonable to
add and by the way, this governor is vaccinated
or this governor is unvaccinated if we know it.
Very good idea. Brant wrote in, this is
another one of those where I start wondering,
am I just terrible at communicating information
to my audience or people really misunderstanding?
Last week, we did a segment about the lie that
thousands of people are dying from the vaccine,
that the vaccine is causing death. Brant wrote
to me saying, David vaccinated people are
dying from covid. Let's look at the email, David.
You do a disservice when you say there are no
deaths among vaccinated people. Granted, they are
rare. I know two vaccinated persons who have died.
There are reports from the U.S. and
U.K., a fully vaccinated, people dying,
fully vaccinated. People are dying with variants
beyond Delta. The antibiotics people are crazy.
But you sound just as delusional when you
suggest there are no vaccinated deaths.
Again, I never said that. I said that there is no
evidence the vaccines are the cause of death. Of
course, we know of breakthrough infections.
And although it's a very small percentage
of what we might call a breakthrough death, but
please try to react to what I'm actually saying
rather than what maybe you hope I'm
saying or whatever the case may be.
I never denied vaccinated people died.
What I said is the idea that thousands,
tens of thousands or hundreds of thousands
of people are dying from the vaccine
is not backed up by any facts, by any evidence
that we are actually seeing. Andrew wrote in,
Andrew says, just you wait. Oh, I can't tell if
this is a joke. I just this is not someone that
has written to us before. I can't tell if this is
satire. Andrew wrote just you wait, sers. You guys
are having a great time mocking Donald Trump,
but just you wait until he unveils Obamacare,
then you will be laughing out of the other side of
your faces. It's the biggest political scandal in
the history of the U.S., perhaps the biggest in
all of history. No, really. You'll see, Andrew,
I think this is satire, the use of Zeus
as well as. No, really, you'll see. And
extraneous exclamation points, including double
exclamation points. I think this is a satirist
who is just kidding around and they're not really
telling us to wait for Obama. John from Jefferson
City, Missouri, wrote in and says, Good day, sir.
Just curious about whether statistics have been
collected to determine the percentage of Democrat
versus Republican that have died from covid-19.
This is a fantastic question. Why? I don't know.
No, this is a fantastic question because we've
been saying for a while, as blue states get
more vaccinated and red states lag behind,
as Republicans remain one of the most anti vaccine
groups in the country, at some point you would
imagine the virus will kill more Republicans than
Democrats. I believe we are already at that point
in time. Earlier this week on the Tube Tuesday
show, on the Tuesday show, we looked at a chart
that looked at per capita deaths over the last few
weeks compared to twenty twenty voting. And what
we saw was that the heaviest Biden states,
places like Vermont, Massachusetts, etc.,
have the lowest per capita death rate, the
biggest Trump states, Mississippi, Alabama,
etc., have the highest per capita death rate
over the last month. This leads me to believe
we are already seeing a skew covid is killing more
American Republicans than American Democrats. Is
it enough to make a difference in elections? We
don't know yet. Could it be make or break in any
particular race? It's too early to say and maybe
not. But my guess would be when we see covid
killing more people per capita in Alabama than
Massachusetts or in Mississippi than in Vermont,
I would guess that the data would bear out.
It's not just people in those states dying. It's
overwhelmingly and disproportionately Republicans
in those states dying. And if you have more
Republicans in a certain state, you would imagine
that it's disproportionately Republicans over
Democrats as well. But a very, very good
question, and it probably is increasingly
already a Republican virus. Here's a couple
bonus. Here is John Lemon from YouTube who says,
so I blame you, Mr Pacman, for the deaths of
15000 Americans that have died from taking the
vaccine. Here's an example of a vaccine.
Detlor As we maybe we would call them,
you were a sick, deranged person who was making
big money off of Big Pharma to say what you say,
prove it. This has come up a dozen times, why
would anyone pay me to talk about a vaccine
were meaningless in the grand scheme of things?
Why wouldn't why would even if there was the
volition to do that, why would anyone give
me money to talk about? I got vaccinated and
it seems to be a good thing to do. John Lehman
goes on to say, I bet also the deep state and
China are paying you off. You were a disgrace
to this country. Very, very sick individual,
very sick individual, not even worth
refuting them on the merits. It's just,
you know, you guys know this stuff is around
that. That is another virus that is spreading.
John Smith wrote in. In response to our
announcement of one billion YouTube views,
John Smith wrote back. One billion idiots see the
Durham report? Yeah, looks like the Democrats were
the ones spreading the Trump Russia B.S. Hillary
herself new. Can't wait for more indictments. This
is someone who still thinks Hillary is going
to prison. This will be very big. But Trump,
he was right with being spied on. Russia Hoke's
election fraud next. The syntax is tough here.
John Smith goes on. How about you? Did you going
did you doing any reporting on Trump and Russia
collusion? I bet Trump's lawyers are at work
getting ready to start lability, lawsuits.
He was slandered. Investigated how many times?
Siff Cuomo at CNN and CNN to get this so wrong by
the media. I hope he's compensated. That is really
tough to get through. John finishing his email to
me, his love letter, by saying one of these
days you will appreciate Trump, the president
and what he did in four years is remarkable.
Don't hold your breath, John. And then lastly,
an extra special bonus in this week's mailbag.
This one coming in very early this morning, five
twenty a.m. via Facebook. You are a worthless
piece of S.H. T piece spelled like world peace.
It's a ho like you that are it's, by
the way, the rockets that are destroying
my country, take your effing ass back to your
own country. I'm an American citizen or reeducate
your regurgitated garbage. This is really, really
weaponized stuff and the prototypical example of
you're not going to sit down with this person,
I'm going to say this guy, almost everyone who
sends stuff like this is male. You're not going
to sit down with this guy and have a rational
conversation and get him to say, you know what?
Right. You're I was wrong. You were right. I'm
glad that you explain things to me the way they
are. It's just not happening. And so it gets us
once again to the question of how do you deprogram
that? How do you do it? I don't have the answer,
but we've talked with a lot of people who claim to
have some ideas. They say the only answer is long
term of building relationships with these folks.
I don't have the I don't have the stomach for it,
I think is the way I would say. And I
know many of you have folks like these
in your family. I'm sorry to hear that. We've got
a great bonus show for you today. Sign up at join
Pakman dot com. You'll get instant access and you
can email me info at David Pakman dot com. Keep
it nice, keep it nice. Give me something
productive we'll see you on the bonus show